this is the most famous Brazilian drink
it's called caipirinha and its whole
soul is sugar it has crystals of sugar
at the bottom to make it sweet and then
it has alcohol which is also made from
sugar I'm in Brazil in Rio de Janeiro
and one of the things that Brazil is
famous for is sugar sucrose one of my
earliest memories about science was when
I was given a dictionary of science when
I was about 10 years old and I was
looking through it and I saw sucrose
sugar and I saw the chemical formula c12
h22 o11 and I thought it was really
crazy
how could sugar advic Emma Cole formula
and that was one of the things that
began to get me interested in chemistry
so sucrose is a compound which contains
two rings joined together one ring is
the sugar glucose and the other is
fructose and they joined together you
will know what it looks like a nice
white crystals these are quite small
crystals here
they contain carbon and hydrogen and
oxygen and you've seen from some of our
other videos if you put concentrated
acid on this you can remove the water
and just release the carbon but in
Brazil one of the things that they do is
to ferment huge quantities of sugar to
make ethanol alcohol and they use it to
power their cars and they also use it to
make their drinks this is one of the
most famous Brazilian drinks is called
caipirinha and you can see it is
actually full of sugar at the bottom
which is why it makes it
cloudy and the liquid is a drink that is
made by fermenting sugar and then
distilling it so it contains about 45%
ethanol
so here you have ethanol and the sugar
but what makes it special what makes it
Brazilian is the fact that they add
fruit and the fruit sometimes with skin
sometimes without the skin and they
usually use limes or sometimes they use
lemons you can make hyperemia either by
using vodka or using a Brazilian drink
called Casa and the traditional one uses
Casa but on the menu here in the
restaurant you can get it with vodka
it's cheaper but the difference between
vodka and Casa is that vodka is made by
fermenting grain so you need a heavy
weight of grain to make the alcohol but
sugar is much more concentrated sugar is
what is used for making Casa and when
you ferment that you get an awful lot of
alcohol for each kilo of sugar
yeah it's far too sweet I'll leave it
for Brady to drink you can also make
sucrose from a root vegetable called
sugar beet and this is what is done in
Britain and most of the European Union
because it's not hot enough to grow
sugar cane sugar beets does not have as
much sugar in it as sugar cane but you
can still get a large amount of sucrose
out of it and the European Union has a
subsidy for farmers who grow sugar so
it's quite tempting to import some sugar
from Brazil and pretend you've grown it
and claim the subsidy so how can they
tell what is real sucrose that's been
grown from sugar beet and what's been
grown from sugarcane it's the same
chemical and so there's a very cunning
trick the biochemistry inside the
sugarcane and inside the sugar beet is
different the way they make that plant
makes the sucrose involves slightly
different reactions and because the
rates of these reactions are different
the amount of 13 carbon from the
atmosphere that is incorporated in the
sugar is different for the two plants
the reason for this is that reactions
with 13 carbon go to different speed for
reactions for 12 carbon the difference
isn't very great but with a modern mass
spectrometer you can tell the difference
so when you go and ask for money for
your sugar they test it with a mass
spectrometer
and if the ratio is wrong you're
cheating in your court